first up if you were given the
opportunity to swap roles with anybody
and the Star Wars film franchise who
would you pick and why oh that's a good
question it's hard to answer on the fly
everyone so far or almost everyone has
said you me yes oh it has to be someone
within the any film you want probably
Jabba the Hutt he doesn't have to go
anywhere people give him grapes a lot he
has like a little guy that runs errands
for him he doesn't have to worry about
weight or time or really anything he
gets to watch a show where you know this
is going to a dark place where there's
death and murder and he just enjoys it
I'll skip over that I'll just say Jabba
the Hutt for personal reasons going away
to those cute creature direction right
now everybody's super into baby Yoda
arts all over the place so we're doing
baby Yoda's first so think baby's first
so if you had the opportunity to see
baby Yoda's first fill in the blank what
would it be so first I don't know bath
Christmas Oh weird something like that
first time eating peanut butter
that's what I'd pick ivory I'm like the
biggest peanut butter fan in the world
so you just won this game
all right great now to this movie a
little and all three actually it was
curious what do you think the movies and
the trilogy overall have got out of
passing the story baton from JJ to Ryan
and back to JJ that it might not have
had had it been one director or a
different director on all three
installments well there's certainly
ideas that I think JJ had that you know
that he let go of anyway I don't know if
that would have been different it was
you know so it it forces you to shake up
your idea
the one thing that and and again I think
it's also the nature of creating
anything you have your idea even at the
start of your movie of what you it's
gonna be and then over the course of it
you know because you have to give it
away too
people you give it to the actors you
give it to the set design to give it to
costumes it evolves into something that
you don't anticipate so I don't think
you could ever anticipate what its gonna
start out as and what it finishes I when
I met JJ he told me in our first meeting
and overall arc for this character where
he would start the last movie no one
knew how it would end
even when we kind of started this we
didn't really know how it was gonna end
so that was really exciting also it says
you know a six it was a six year journey
that you know we were building toward so
it affects all your choices and force
awakens and last Jedi that you know
finally you're putting a cap on
something hopefully mm-hmm one of my
favorite things about kylo Ren in
particular is that yeah maybe you could
label him a big bad but he also has a
lot of very vulnerable moments in these
movies so if you could pick the one
moment in this trilogy where he came
across as the most empathetic or human
to you which moment would you pick
that's hard to maybe a moment in weight
over the first two movies I've got a
whole list in my head you go without the
other one I there's you really there is
a lot there's a lot to choose from and
I'm not just being vague but they're
there hopefully this one there's a good
moment where you really see him maybe
III I hope I mean I don't know that
we've been talking about with people
before about masks and that's such a
huge you know iconography of Star Wars
that you just that we took for granted
that we had to reimagine so what is it
about someone who hides himself you know
or presents the person to the world but
underneath is something completely
different and I think for the maybe
there's a moment in this one where
that's surprising that's so one unsung
hero rise of Skywalker who would it be
and why one unsung hero yeah because we
know the ensemble we know JJ very well
but is there anyone maybe like a PA or
someone
a craft service that had you covered one
day when you really needed it that made
a difference in your work Amanda my
dresser you know I've been with her for
six years from the very beginning and
that costume similar to the character
has evolved it started off and and still
it you know it's boast it was supposed
to be ill-fitting it to you know
manifest physically what was going on
internally
maybe he's uncomfortable it's helmets
you know not polished and and always at
the end of all of these takes you had my
dresser or Amanda who we had we had
gotten things to a short cut we just
knew each other so intimately and she
sees me after after things before things
thank you for that question I get to
relive that with that you know no one
would really know but she was an
important part of my day because I
things he really can't reach and she's
also so much shorter than I am so I have
to duck a lot you know we found a good
good way of working